We're at that moment.
Pardon me a second here.
You know, I always find
it shocking that you,
you get to spring
break, and you come back,
and you're like, "Oh
my god, six more weeks.
How am I going to survive?"
And the next thing you know,
we're at the last week of
class, the last lecture.
And since it is
the last lecture,
I want to do a quick
survey of the course,
and this is truly a quick
survey of the course through
a whole host of keywords.
This is not meant to
sum up the entire course,
and I'm not saying that all
these keywords are going to
help you understand
your final paper or ace,
you know, the in-class exam,
for those of you who are
going to be taking it.
But they, I think,
will--they are there to spur
more reflection and thought
about critical moments,
themes,
ideologies for the class.
And then I do want to bring
us up to our contemporary
moment and wrestle for a
little bit about some of the
lessons, discussions,
ideas from the past,
and how they resonate
in our present time.
So--is this working?
Excellent.
Okay.
So it should--unless you're
coming to the class for the
first time
today, not pre-frosh,
who might be here, but
people in the class,
if, if I have to
linger over citizenship,
I wish you much luck
for the end of the term.
Citizenship is one of the,
the fundamental issues that
I've been talking about
throughout this course,
whether it's the active
attempt to deny citizenship
in the, in the
pre-emancipatory moment and
the
post-emancipatory moment,
or whether it's just the
various ways individuals,
state actors, ideologies
have worked to police who
could belong and not belong
in the American pantheon.
Representation, I'm
talking about it,
how--I, I mean, think about
it in the way that we use
cultural symbols to
represent other things,
the ways in which different
ideologies of the self,
in terms of racialized
self-representation,
ethnic, sexual
orientation, gender,
all of these things
representing a whole body,
as it were, of political
positions and ideologies.
One of the great things
that is there through the
beginning of the course and
all the way to the present
day is really the wrestling
and the balance between
where does one's rights
as an individuals run
into--[Student
Sneezes] Bless you--run,
run into larger issues
dealing with the social
fabric, individual liberty
versus social equality.
And you can certainly
translate that into,
metaphorically, into states'
rights versus federal rights
as well.
This is a major thing that
we've been talking about,
I've been trying to impart
to you the last couple of
lectures, certainly, but
it's been there throughout
the course, the great divide
between the rhetoric of our
political leaders or
our political activists,
politically engaged people,
and what social reality is.
This is certainly an
important thing to wrestle
with, think about, in
the last twenty or thirty
years--well, gosh, now
thirty or forty years,
in our post-civil
rights movement era.
But how can we talk about
race as it's lived on the
ground, and not--as a
politician or activist?
How can I talk about race
as it's lived on the ground
without being tarred,
correctly or incorrectly,
as being racialist or
racist in my thinking?
Dealing with issues of
leadership of course,
and uplift.
These come together,
certainly if you think back
to earlier part of the
course and the complicated
politics, often class
politics and gender
politics, all woven
through with race politics,
about what does uplift mean?
What does it mean
to lead the race?
Uplift them to what,
uplift them from what?
Uplift them, but so far.
These are all these kinds
of things we talked about.
Chronologically speaking,
mainly I talked about them
at the turn of the century
going into the twentieth
century.
Part of uplift, part of
uplift is respectability,
people acting in a
respectable fashion,
but that's certainly not
a phenomenon that limits
itself to the late
nineteenth century,
early twentieth century.
I mean, think of the
images of the civil rights
activists that we saw, that,
that we've grown up with:
you know, young men and
young women having to dress
in a certain way, comport
themselves in a certain
fashion.
Think of the stories I
talked about with the
Little--Little
Rock Nine or the,
the men who integrated the
Woolworth's lunch counter in
Greensboro, North Carolina,
and started the sit-in
movement.
Think of the way that Martin
Luther King had to present
himself, felt the
need to present himself,
the test case individuals
who end up--their cases go
up to the Supreme Court.
They had to reflect or
embody the kind of values
that they felt the
nation could understand.
These are the most
respectable people,
and how can we deny them
their citizenship rights?
Gender, of course, and
its see--and its seeming
invisibility.
Throughout the
course and its readings,
I know in sections as
well, issues have--of,
of gender have
been ever present.
They're always present,
and in some weeks more
explicitly than others, but
the way in which women's and
men's rights or, quote,
"sensibilities"--I use that
term very gently in a fully
loaded fashion--shift how we
deal with individual
rights, social equality,
certainly, who
can be a citizen?
Thinking of
things on the ground,
you have the migrations,
the Great Migration
her--happening in the
early part of the twentieth
century, the much larger
migration as far as numbers
happening in the
1940s and 1950s,
and coming along with
the relocation of African
American bodies is also
American culture, forms
of cultural expression,
politics, organizing
logics, traditions,
and also
resistance, and unrest,
and riots, and bloodshed.
At different moments in
the course I talked about
cultural politics, whether
the Harlem Renaissance or
the New Negro Renaissance,
and introduced the idea,
at least for this course,
about the belief by many of
the leaders of the
Renaissance that practicing
cultural
politics in this way,
talking about exceptional
cultural talents of the
race, was absolutely
a politicized act.
That by recognizing the
cultural gifts of black
people in the world,
think to the connections,
the complicated connections,
to African cultural roots,
but by talking about the
cultural gifts of African
Americans, the nation would
understand these people have
made a contribution and they
needed to be recognized in
such a way and have
their citizenship rights
respected.
Certainly
throughout the course,
we've been talking
about political radicalism,
but, you know, keep in
mind this is chronologically
contingent.
The NAACP were a bunch of
crazy radicals--The leaders
of the NAACP were a bunch
of crazy radicals in 1909,
always espousing
middle-class norms,
but still radicals.
By the time you
get to mid-century,
they aren't
necessarily the radicals,
you know, and they're trying
to silence people like
Rob--Robert Williams,
saying blacks need to arm
themselves.
It's like, "We can't have
that in our association."
And then by the
sixties and seventies,
you know, they're
yesterday's news as far as
the young
radicals are concerned.
What is radical is
contingent upon time and
place.
Certainly when you think
about the civil rights
movement in
particular, as I,
you know, remember, I slowed
down the pace of the course
dramatically, because the
iconography of the civil
rights movement
is so powerful,
it's one of the defining
characteristics of our,
of our modern--I mean modern
in the last forty years,
let's say--of our modern
conception of what it means
to be an American.
It means that we all
supported Martin Luther
King, after all.
We all overcame, you know,
the struggles that people
with a less sharp
vision created.
Well, the fact is,
that's all a myth.
There's only a minority of
a minority who were on the
front lines with
King and other people,
and of course, King being
iconographic himself and
many other people involved.
And there's
profound resistance,
individual,
institutional, cultural,
to change in the movement.
But the iconography gives us
a kind of simplified notion
of the civil rights history
that does a disservice to
all the real
struggles on the ground,
and all the complications
that come along with being a
human being.
Talk of the
triumphs of--I mean,
two great iconographic
moments were the signing of
the Civil Rights Act and
the Voting Rights Act.
Moments where it seems that
African Americans finally
had their full
rights as citizens.
But you need to understand,
this might connect across
the way to political
rhetoric versus social
reality.
So you can pass all the
laws you want to pass,
but unless you
enforce those laws,
it doesn't mean anything.
So the Civil Rights and
Voting Rights Acts were
signed and ushered in a, a
new day for all American
citizens.
There's no
minimizing that fact;
it did.
But you also have to
look at enforcement,
you have to wrestle
with the phenomenon that,
say, the Supreme
Court in Brown v.
Board, saying
"we need to end,
end segregation with
all deliberate speed."
And these things are still
tied up in court cases,
to this day.
Enforcement being very
critical when it comes to
citizenship
rights and the law.
Heading more towards
our contemporary moment,
of course, where we've been
for the last four weeks of
the course--no, I'm
sorry, last two weeks of the
course--with greater
focus is post-civil rights
America.
What does it mean to
be post-civil rights?
Historians are actually
actively debating this right
now, wondering if we ever
got to a post-civil rights
moment, and also wondering,
did the civil rights--and
I've already mentioned
this in the course,
did the civil
rights movement begin,
say, in '54?
Can you actually
identify the beginning?
Did it end in '68?
Can you identify an
ending, actually?
So, we all use the
phrase post-civil rights,
I mean, I use it as well.
But we need to understand
that it's loaded with
complications.
It's a highly nuanced term
that's never thought about
in a nuanced way or
used in a nuanced way,
except for you guys
after this class.
Racial symbolism has
been there from the very
beginning, the
founding of this country,
before the
founding of this country.
It is a phenomenon that
exists as long as people
have eyeballs.
Now, it is a defining
characteristic of this
country.
It's--John Hope Franklin,
the historian I mentioned in
the last lecture, who
headed up the President's
commission on the, the
National Conversation on
Race, you know, said this
is America's original sin.
This is the scar that
really defines the country.
Angela Oh
disagreed with him to the,
to the extent to which he
thought--she thought that
that was a really useful way
of thinking about things,
but the fact is, as I
mentioned in the very first
lecture, that--arguing you
cannot understand American
freedom, one of our
most core values,
without
understanding slavery.
And you can't
understand slavery without
understanding its
racial dynamics.
Of course, racial symbolism
carries forward till today
and that's what I'll
actually be talking about a
fair amount in
today's lecture,
about just that.
And, in fact, as
I think about it,
this used to be the last
keyword I'd have on the
screen.
There's many other words
I could pick and choose,
but I thought this was a
nice way to get into the
lecture on racial symbolism.
But now we've got
this one to deal with,
"post-racial."
What does it mean?
What can it possibly mean?
I mean, the, the, the, the
simple answer is that we've
now come to a place
that as a country,
we've elected an
African American President.
Who that we is,
is contingent,
of course, and even an
African American President
is contingent, of course.
But now that we have
done this great thing,
we can now get past this
great burden that has--that
we have of being consumed
with racial politics,
everybody.
And, goodness, I'm
forgetting the talking head
that said as much, but after
Barack Obama's election,
it's like, "Look,
African Americans,
basically you've got nothing
else to complain--I don't
want to hear any
more whining."
Who was that?
Somebody here knows this.
It wasn't Chris Matthews.
He thought for a second
he was going to be able to
forget Barack Obama's
black, for about an hour,
he was that--that was a
triumphant moment for him.
I'm forgetting who it was,
but it was actually a quite
famous comment
that, "All right,
you have nothing
else to complain about.
You've, you've got
your guy in office."
What does it mean
to be post-racial?
I actually had a
conversation about this the
night after Barack
Obama was elected.
I was in Commons--Calhoun
was in renovation then--and
there was one other student.
I was getting there late,
and there was one other
student from
Calhoun in the section,
so I sat down
across from her.
I'm like, "Wow, this is
quite a remarkable moment,
isn't it?"
And she said,
"Professor Holloway,
we just, you know, we, of
our generation (which is a
reminder of yes, I
was twice her age),
you know, we don't think
about these things this way.
We're post-racial."
And, you know, I don't
want to overburden the race,
but this is an African
American student I happened
to be sitting across from.
And she goes, you know,
"This is something that your
generation
(thanks, once again,
for reminding me I'm twice
your age) that you guys are
all con--consumed by."
And the--What she
wouldn't know is,
you know, I don't
remember any of this stuff.
I was too young for that
consum--consumptive moment
of the civil rights era.
That's the
moment of my birth.
So she was like, "We
just don't talk about these
things.
We don't think
about these things."
And I walked away from
that conversation thinking,
"My god, she's
actually right."
That we don't talk about
these things and we don't
think about these
things, but is,
is that what it
means to be post-racial?
And if it does, I'd say
we're actually in a whole
bunch of trouble.
Is it a generational change,
or is it something a little
more complicated?
And I'll argue that
it's more complicated.
So that was the night--the
day after Obama was elected,
and then of course
he's inaugurated.
And it was
fascinating to me,
I mentioned this once
before in the lecture,
that this--I
mean inaugurations,
regardless of
who's taking office,
pretty phenomenal moment,
and a moment I get very
patriotic about, even if I
don't like the person who's
taking office.
The peaceful
transition of power,
it's an astonishing thing.
But as the--and the,
and the inauguration,
I mean the pomp and
circumstance and all the,
you know, the symbolic
weight of the moment is,
I think, really
quite powerful.
This inauguration was
really quite different.
It was texturally rich
in a way that an--other
inaugurations weren't,
and this from somebody who
studies the
African American past.
You have Aretha Franklin
singing "My Country,
'Tis of Thee."
You know because I've
offered the prompt,
I think that's
kind of important,
for reasons I'll
let you explore.
You have
Reverend Joseph Lowry,
a leader of the Southern
Christian Leadership
Conference, one of
King's inner circle,
gets up to offer his prayer.
And a
fascinating thing happens,
sort of after the fact.
From the first moment
he gets up there and,
and starts
talking, I'm like,
"Wow, this is
really powerful.
I know exactly
what he's doing.
He's reading, narrating,
the first words of the,
quote, 'National Black
Anthem.'" And what was
astonishing to discover
is that in a way that I,
I just sort of
found amazing,
in a sense that I was
so close to the topic,
I didn't think that others
didn't get what was going
on, but that
the inaug--that,
that many people,
white Americans,
and other
Americans, different types,
and certainly some
black Americans as well,
had no idea what he
was talking about,
when he was reciting the
lines to "Lift Every Voice
and Sing."
And it made it clear to me,
is that that inauguration,
from a textual
point of view,
was experienced in
very different ways.
There's the obvious point
of view: there's a black
President, you know,
overwhelmingly--overwhelming
majority, a supermajority of
African Americans voting for
him, a, a mixed bag
depending on different
categories beyond that, of
who voted for Barack Obama.
So it's the obvious way in
which the inauguration's
experienced differently.
But from a
textual standpoint,
and the way in which the
inauguration was really
quite historically minded,
was really quite something,
and the way that that
history was experienced or
acknowledged differently,
that many people basically
didn't understand the
subtext of Aretha Franklin's
performance, or the
subtext of Reverend Lowry's
performance, or even
the night when Obama was
elected, at Grant
Park in Chicago,
his invocation of words that
are sort of central to the
civil rights
movement heritage,
quotes Martin Luther King,
but never references King.
It's really quite
something, actually,
the way in which Obama or
his inner circle are making
all of these connections
often to the African
American past,
without referencing it.
Maybe that's
post-racial, I don't know.
Now when Obama was
running for office,
so two years ago, in this
course at the one of the
very first
lectures, I was saying,
you know, "Look, I'm not
going to talk--"--you know,
Hillary Rodham Clinton
and, and Barack Obama were
shaping up to be the
major contenders for the
Democratic Party,
the nomination,
and I told the class,
"Look, I know this is rather
important.
Of course it's important.
It's an historic
elec--election for the
Democrats no matter what.
I'm not going to talk about
it at the beginning of the
course.
I'll talk about it
in the last lecture."
What I wasn't telling
the students is like "when
Hillary Rodham Clinton will
probably heading--be heading
towards the nomination,
and Barack Obama will have
dropped out."
In my head, it's
what I was thinking.
Thinking of the
history of, of,
like the "Angry Hands"
advertisement with Harvey
Gantt and Jesse Helms, I
frankly presumed it was just
a matter of time when we
started going to the ballot
boxes and the, the
voting booths that,
although people were curious
and excited about this
eloquent junior senator,
that when it came to
actually casting the vote
that--I thought that Hillary
Clinton would
basically run away with it.
And then Obama goes on what
was an eleven state tear,
something like that, crushes
the history of what Jesse
Jackson had done.
And I'm realizing
during the course,
like "Oh boy, I've got
to rewrite the end of my
course."
This is act--something,
something different is
happening here.
And then, as we are heading
towards spring break,
that moment of,
you know, "Boy,
we're all so tired and we've
just got to struggle through
the last six
weeks of the course,
then the news starts to
break about Reverend Wright,
Obama's pastor in,
in Trinity Church,
Rev--Reverend Jeremiah
Wright and his racial views,
a church that he'd been
leading for a long time and
Obama had gone to.
And what happened
next was actually,
I thought,
rather predictable.
There's lots and
lots of hot air,
all sides of the
political--all spots in the
political spectrum weighing
in about Reverend Wright's
racism, or his
racial honesty,
and everything in between,
and where--what's Obama
thinking?
What happened
after that was,
I thought, quite
astonishing though.
Obama gives his so-called
race speech in Philadelphia,
"A More Perfect Union,"
that two years ago in the
edition--actually,
even last year,
I believe, in the
edition of the,
the Manning Marable
reader--was it even in last
year's edition?
No, it wasn't there yet.
They, they
re-purposed the book,
and that's in
the documents now.
Now there was the expected
repudiation of some of
Wright's views in
Obama's speech.
People expected that.
But, remarkably,
there wasn't an apology.
It's kind of astonishing.
Obama addressed in his
speech Wright's ideas,
as one would expect,
distanced himself from some
of them, but he
gave a lecture really,
and I think lecture is
the appropriate word,
on the scar of race
throughout American history.
It was an acknowledgement
that everyone had to be more
honest about
racism, everyone,
about the racism
they express or feel,
and that they had to
recognize that race was
often used as a
veil, as it were,
to mask other issues.
Think back to Du
Bois where, you know,
people who were
black hid behind a veil,
or put--society put a
veil in front of them.
Obama's talking
about a different way,
that race is the actual
veil that's shielding,
hiding,
obfuscating other issues.
Obama also said that there
were lingering scars that we
as a nation had to admit to.
We had to admit to all of
this and recognize that the
feelings were
still very real,
and that Wright's
views made sense,
even though they might sound
repugnant to many people,
that they made sense to
many people as well in the
African American community.
And that if we're ever to
get beyond any of this,
it was time that we actually
be honest about this scar,
and how we can
make a better world.
It's a powerful speech.
I was actually on spring
vacation and really trying
to be on spring vacation.
I was in Florida
with my family.
And I knew that he was
going to give this speech,
but I also knew
that I had, you know,
rented a boat that I was
going to--by goodness,
I was going to
take that boat out,
and so I was going
to miss the speech.
And I get, we get
back after the day,
and there's
messages on my email,
email and my voice mail,
from different reporters
wanting comment.
I'm like, "Oh, guess
the speech actually was
well-received,
or controversial,
or something."
I didn't know the first
thing about the speech.
Then I start seeing--looking
at the email more
carefully--or the
headlines, I'm sorry.
"The most important
political speech in the
nation's history."
"The most important
speech since Gettysburg."
"More important than 'I
Have a Dream.'" I'm like,
"Oh my, what the
heck did this man say?"
I've got to find out.
So right away I
go to C-SPAN,
and they already
have it posted.
So I, I watch,
listen to the speech,
and what I found so
astonishing in this--I mean,
I already told you the
things I thought were
important about it, but a
major reason that it was
astonishing is that our
national discourse on race
is so impoverished that they
didn't know how to handle a
very honest and rich speech
that's full of complication
and nuance.
People didn't know
what to do with it,
and certainly didn't know
what to do with it from a,
a politician
running for something.
Who gives a speech like
that when you're running for
office?
The fact is, race is
easy at its surface.
It's--allows us to ignore
more complicated realities.
It allows us to engage in
simple coding of behaviors,
of people, of types.
It's a social
convention, essentially,
that, that is in each
of us, racial thinking.
And I'm not ab--I'm not
absolving myself of that
either.
I'd be a liar if I were.
What I want to do for the
rest of the lecture is talk
about how race is used,
something historically,
certainly.
It's all
grounded in history,
but also bringing it up to
the contemporary moment.
I don't want to, I don't
want to overburden the
importance of the speech.
It was, I think, an
important speech,
certainly, but I want to
build off of sort of the way
we can use moments like
this to think historically,
and with nuance, and
also about our contemporary
moments.
So I want to look, talk
about how race is used.
Now we know from other
moments in the course,
but also on Monday's
lecture specifically,
that race is used
to criminalize.
I mean, this is something
I've made quite plain,
and you have--I
don't have it today;
it would just be repetitive,
but in the case of O.J.
Simpson, certainly with
the Time magazine cover and
darkening his features to
make him look more like a
criminal.
Race is used in
that way, okay,
but in this case, thinking
about the way that race is
the veil that
hides other things.
O.J.
Simpson's race allows us to
ignore the fact that we're
talking about a really
wealthy man in that case.
Was it about a
superstar and his ex-wife?
Was it about a black person
and his--and a black man and
his white wife, ex-wife?
Or was it about
someone with a lot of power,
cultural capital and money,
and someone who doesn't have
it?
Race would, I mean, we got
so fixated on race in that
trial, we ignored
the class dynamic.
And I only linger on
this for a half second,
because at the same
time, I think in California,
a rather similar set of
circumstances transpired
with a black man
and his white wife.
He did not have money.
Curious sets of,
you know, evidence,
abuse, and whatever.
The guy was put in jail
and never heard from again.
Can't ignore the role that
money plays in a situation
like that, but race
allows us to walk around it.
Race is used in that way.
It's used to distract.
It's used, of
course, to sell products,
and these are some
images that you may
remember--things like them
from Ethnic Notions very
early in the term, being
used to sell Cream of Wheat.
It says here, "Maybe
Cream of Wheat ain't got no
vitamins.
I don't know what
them things is.
If they's bugs, they ain't
none in Cream of Wheat,
but she's sho' good
to eat and cheap.
Cost bout 1¢ fo' a
great big dish."
Sung by Rastus,
which is one of the,
the caricatures of
the, the happy servant,
the loyal servant.
Now Cream of Wheat
isn't sold this way now,
but in the early 1970s, it
had just moved away from
this.
I remember, this was when I
was eating Cream of Wheat.
Certainly, you know, the
vernacular dialect had
disappeared at that point,
but Rastus Anonymous was
still there,
selling Cream of Wheat.
More famously, you have
Aunt Jemima: pancakes,
southern
cooking, the matron,
the, the mammy figure, with
her natural knowledge of how
to take care of people.
As you head into the
1980s and nineties,
people think, you know,
"This might be a little
dated, this, you
know, Aunt Jemima figure.
Maybe we should revisit it."
And they did, and so Aunt
Jemima lost the do-rag,
and the, you know,
the handkerchief,
and the other
conventional dress,
got an up-do.
You can't see
on the pic--the,
the, the quality of the
image is poor--a nice set of
pearls, so when she
comes back from work,
like she can still make
great pancakes for you,
but, but she got updated,
she got professionalized.
People were getting a
little bit queasy about the
lingering vestiges of what
many people felt was the
racism being used
to peddle pancakes.
And I'll be honest, I mean I
grew up with Aunt Jemima in
the house, and for
the love of god,
I didn't understand why.
I mean, I didn't have the
words or the education then
to really understand
what, what I was feeling,
but something I found
really--it kind of bothered
me.
And I was not a little
Malcolm X running around,
you know,
trying to, you know,
beat down the man
and do these things.
It just didn't feel right,
but I didn't know why.
Then my family
switched to Vermont Maid,
which is loaded with all
kinds of other kinds--you
know, it's, it's
all bad syrup,
frankly, but, but--and I
don't know what Aunt Jemima
pancakes taste like, because
I don't eat them anymore,
but I know people
do swear by them.
But if you don't
want pancakes,
maybe you want rice.
There's Uncle Ben.
Growing out of the same
tradition of Rastus and Aunt
Jemima, loyal
and happy servant,
and they're all
smiling, right?
Well, Uncle Ben has
been peddling rice pilaf,
basically, a whole
variety of rice products,
for the longest time, and
then the ad people started
getting a little nervous
about Uncle Ben and thought,
"Maybe this is not
really--let's distance
ourselves from Uncle Ben."
And so he disappeared
from the packages.
Then about five years
ago, he reappeared.
I think, I think
Proctor and Gamble,
they own pretty
much everything,
decided, you
know, "It's time.
I think we can do this.
I think we can have a
more historically rich and
nuanced
understanding of Uncle Ben."
And so much
like Aunt Jemima,
Uncle Ben got a job.
And I did not check
before today's lecture;
it was certainly
the case last year.
If you go to--and
don't do it now,
I mean half you guys...But,
if you go to Uncle--you
know, Google Uncle
Ben, you get the website.
It's a beautiful website.
You walk into the CEO's
office and guess whose
office?
It's Uncle Ben's office!
He's no longer
Uncle Ben, though,
he's just Ben.
Still doesn't
have a last name.
The first name being a
very important tradition of,
of southern social hierarchy
is that black men and women
are always talked to
by their first name,
whether it was actually
their first name or not,
you know.
So Ben is, Ben--it's,
it's not CEO Gates;
it's just Ben.
And the website, it is, it
was really quite a work of
art, but in the
version five years ago,
you could walk around his
desk and open up the day
planner, and it
would talk about him,
"wink, wink,"--and I'm very
closely paraphrasing--having
libations with the
southern sen--southern,
southern senator.
You know, "this is
the way we do business,
or something like that.
I thought, "Wow, so
somebody thought it was
appropriate--"--I mean,
they'd already given Ben a
big raise.
He's the CEO.
They thought it
was appropriate,
though, to harken back to a
tradition of good old boys
and behaving
inappropriately,
and now CEO
Uncle, Uncle CEO,
is one of these boys.
I mean, think back to Birth
of a Nation and the story of
the black
Reconstruction governments,
and they're eating
chicken legs--oh no,
turkey legs, and drinking,
and taking their shoes off.
It's in that same
kind of tradition.
That's kind of astonishing.
I went back last
year, that thing's gone.
The rest of the
site is still there,
but that part is gone.
So someone raised a fuss.
I mean, when, when
they brought Ben back,
there was a whole
bunch of, like "Wow,
this is a crazy idea."
But still Ben is--at
least, at least through last
year--I didn't check
the website last night,
and I don't shop
for Uncle Ben's,
so I don't know if he's
still smiling at us in the,
in the aisle ways.
I suspect that he is.
Now this is--corporate
makeovers are not limited
just to the African
American experience.
There is a campaign to
freshen Betty Crocker,
the face of Betty Crocker,
and you see her through the
ages from 1927
until she ends up,
well, looking
like a wise Latina,
perhaps, in 1996.
And when, when, when
this makeover came about,
there was a lot
of discussion,
like wow.
I mean Betty
Crocker didn't say,
you know, what ethnic
identity she was supposed to
have.
She was just Betty Crocker.
People think
that looks like,
you know, a very
professional Latina.
And heck if you look at
the demographics of this
country, that may be a
smart marketing trend,
going, going ahead a
couple of decades.
So race is used
to sell things,
absolutely, and this is
just barely the tip of the
iceberg.
It's still being
used to sell things.
Race is also used to suggest
progressive commitment to
equality.
University,
University of Wisconsin,
year 2000, put out a
magazine for something like
"Bulldog days," frankly,
for their version of it,
"Badger days," I don't know.
I'm making that up.
But, but this was a
brochure they'd hand out,
a magazine, talking about
all those great things that
Wisconsin,
University of Wisconsin,
has and does.
Exactly the kind of thing
you would expect from a
university.
I've absolutely no quarrel
with the content of the
magazine.
So that's the image, that's
the copy of the image,
and if you look,
follow the--my mouse,
you see all of these
happy students at probably a
football game.
And then you see him, a
happy African American
student at a football game.
That's, that's great.
Here's the real image.
He's not there.
Now, you have to
go back ten years.
Photoshop was
very new, okay.
This was just
being rolled out.
And the idea--now we--you've
grown up with--I mean,
everything is
Photoshopped, right?
It wasn't in 2000.
This was a new technology,
and so they took--someone
who was looking at
the magazine said,
"You know, it's funny,
because the light's all
coming from a
certain angle here,
but it's coming from a
different angle over here.
And, you know, it
just kind of--just the,
the biometrics
don't seem quite right,
and someone slipped the
actual--this is what the
cover is.
Now actually, I have a
friend I recruited from the
University of Wisconsin,
Professor Blackhawk.
Some of you may know him.
He actually brought--and I
meant to bring it today,
I forgot--one of his friends
at Wisconsin is still there,
and gave to him to give
to me the actual copy.
I mean, I actually
have one of these things.
It's very cool.
And then here's
the real image.
Now this young man, as it
turns out--and this was
taken at, at, like
a student bazaar.
He was a very happy
University of Wisconsin
student.
He was a student leader.
He was engaged in
all kinds of things.
There's no doubt that he was
enthusiastic about being at
Wisconsin, but the fact
is, he wasn't there at that
moment.
And you can see, they
actually turned the face in
the opposite direction,
did all of these different
things.
Now Wisconsin is not trying
to say black folks aren't
welcome.
They're trying the opposite.
"Look, there's a black
person at the football game!
We are a school
that--"--I mean,
and, and, it does not,
it's not a diverse school.
It's not a diverse state,
but they are really trying,
in this
publication at least,
symbolically, to try to
do something different.
Race is used in
socially progressive ways,
even if
sometimes accidentally.
This is a statue at North
Carolina A&T in Greensboro,
very close to Woolworth's
where the sit-in movement
began, and this is a
representation of the four
men who are now
university heroes.
And if you go to
downtown Greensboro,
which was, after the
textile mills closed,
there's nothing in
downtown Greensboro.
My grandmother lives nearby,
so I was driving around and
come across--you can't see
here--February One Street.
I mean, "That's a
weird name for a street,
and it turns out it's right
at the intersection of the
Woolworth's building.
And Woolworth's building--oh
and there's placards in the,
in the ground, representing
the four men walking there,
and this is the, the
Woolworth's building,
the site of the
that the city fathers
wanted take--they wanted to
eliminate the history of the
Woolworth's building and the
sit-in for the longest time.
It's an embarrassing part
of Greensboro's history.
Preservationists said,
"You've got to save this
thing," and then
people got together and,
for years, were working on
building an international
civil rights
center and museum.
It took well over a decade
and they actually just
opened up this February, on
the fiftieth anniversary of
the sit-in.
I haven't been to it yet,
but I'm looking forward to
going.
But, so, what
does this matter?
How, how is race
being used here?
There is nothing in
Greensboro any more.
Southern cities, now
that industry has gone,
are re--trying to rebuild
their downtown cores by
creating heritage sites.
A place of
social, and political,
and racial shame is now
being turned into--and the,
the New York Times
review said it's a fantastic
museum--a place to
draw in tourist money.
Birmingham is the same way.
The, the attack dogs
that Bull Connor released,
had released, to go
after the student pro--the,
the, the
protestors, you know,
at the park,
there--it's now a memorial.
You have the, the, the,
German shepherds frozen in a
very modernistic pose.
People travel throughout
the South in bus rides,
sometimes
organized by universities,
to witness these places.
There's a lot of
money at stake.
Race is being used.
It's used in a conflated
way to honor and to sell a
product.
This is an image that
needs no narration.
You know, it's King at
the "I have a--"--March on
Washington.
An advertisement,
"Before you can inspire,
before you can touch,
you must first connect."
It's by Alcatel, a wireless
phone service in 2001,
and a suggestion.
You know, even whether
it's Photoshopped or just a,
you know, created image,
that if only King had a good
cell phone service, we'd
have something different.
Now you all grew
up after, I guess,
"Forrest Gump" was out, but
this was very controversial
when it came out, very
popular but controversial,
with historians, like
"What are you doing,
you know, playing around
fast and loose with history
like this?"
As Forrest Gump--this was,
they leave characters all
over the place, and
wondering what--how history
would have been
different, you know,
in this case, had King
had a different product,
and just as
Forrest Gump was,
you know, there at
all these places,
you know, changing
history quite by accident.
Americans are
really bad historians,
so professional historians
get anxious when they see
something like this, even
though it may be clever.
Now King is certainly
a political football,
whether it's the California
Civil Rights Initiative or,
you know,
progressives, conservatives,
they all use King.
In the Oakland school
district--goodness,
about, I want to say
seven or eight years ago
now--there was a major
debate about Ebonics.
The question is, Ebonics,
would it be recognized as a
form of American dialect,
and if it was--English
dialect, and if it
was--there would be actual
institutional support for
helping these kids who speak
Ebonics, nonstandard
American English,
to help them with extra
support and tutoring,
you know, in
Ebonics vernacular,
as a way to be--eventually
mainstream them.
Clear
representation of King,
you know, "I has a
dream," that would be,
you know, King if he
were speaking in Ebonics.
And the text is very
small down here and it says,
"Does this bother you?"
(This is from,
[clears throat] excuse me,
October '98.
I just have the
date here, I'm sorry,
'98.) "Does this bother you?
It should.
We spent over four hundred
years fighting for the right
to have a voice.
Is this how we'll use it?
More importantly, is this
how we'll teach our children
to use it?
If we expect more of them,
we must not throw our hands
in the air and agree with
those who say our children
cannot be taught.
By now you've probably
heard about Ebonics,
aka, aka black English, and
if you think it's become a
controversy because white
America doesn't want us
messing with their
precious language,
don't.
White America couldn't care
less what we do to segregate
ourselves.
The fact is, language is
power and we can't take that
power away from our
children with Ebonics.
Would Dr.
Martin Luther King,
Malcolm X and all the
others who paid the price of
obtaining our voice with
the currency of their lives
embrace this?
If you haven't used
your voice lately,
consider this
an invitation."
African Americans gathering
together to purchase this
advertisement, railing
against other African
Americans and
blacks and whites,
of course, on both
sides of the line,
about who can speak for the
race and what that race is
going to say.
It's a
contemporary history, race,
this is a satellite image
of Katrina washing ashore.
Now there's a lot to be
said about race and Katrina.
I don't have
time to do that,
but I want to show you two
images from the moment and
talk about the way that
race factored into it.
We all know, of
course, you go to,
you know, Yahoo!
web pages, you know,
any sort of web pages for
breaking news, and they
have a scroll of pictures,
and here's two hundred
pictures from a certain
event and you can
hit the next one,
and the next one,
and the next one.
And they all have a
little bit of script,
very short description.
Now there are journalistic
practices about what the
photojournalist is
supposed to say,
the photographer, to
describe what he or she is
seeing.
There are standards about
what constitutes finding
something, what constitutes
stealing something or
looting something.
So I don't know the
facts of these two pictures,
about what the, the
photographer saw,
but this image runs, and
it shows two white people
having "found"
food in Katrina.
And, you know, there's
carrying bags like orange
juice or groceries,
something like that,
in that bag,
floating along the way.
Two people who found food.
The next image,
as it happened,
was this one, a citizen
who, who "looted" a store,
carrying a, a, a twelve pack
or twenty pack of Pepsi,
and who knows
what in the bag.
The fact is, he may
have looted a store.
The fact is, they may
have found the food.
I'm not
disputing this, okay?
I'm not engaging it, but the
pictures ran right next to
each other, and we are all
so hardwired to presume that
the person
writing this sentence,
or the editor
putting together,
has tripped over a
racial fault line,
that they can't see anything
but a criminal in this
image, and a citizen
in the previous one.
And this was part
of the rhetoric of,
of Katrina, certainly in the
way it was reported in the
news.
Black and brown people
are talked about refugees,
although they were citizens.
But a reason I point to this
is to talk about the way
that we are consumed
with thinking about race,
to a point that we
become quite blinded by it.
I don't have the
time for it right now,
but let me
encourage you to go to,
go to YouTube and
put in "Mike Myers,
Katrina and Kanye West,"
or just "Katrina and Kanye
West," and you'll see more
of what I'm talking about:
race being used to
heighten our emotions,
used in ways that either are
clarifying or destructive,
depending on
your point of view.
Race is very much
past and present.
Even in our
"post-racial" age,
we have controversies like
this one in the New York
Post: two cops having
blown apart a chimpanzee,
"We'll have to find someone
else to write that next
stimulus bill."
The artist saying, "I had
no racist intent at all.
It was just, you know, it
was an attempt at humor,
talking about, you know,
the bill was so crazy,
it must have been
monkeys sitting in a room."
You know, there's a phrase
about--where you put a
hundred monkeys in a
room, you get Shakespeare
eventually that--working
typewriters--but,
but that this is what
he was going after.
He may have been
absolutely honest,
but the way that
this was perceived,
with the long history of
connections between African
Americans and apes, and the
fact the president is behind
signing stimulus bills, that
the--and there's a history
of New York police,
cops, shooting unarmed black
citizens, or
attacking in other ways,
that somebody in the
editorial process in the New
York Post missed
the boat entirely.
Did not see that this
might have been wildly
misinterpreted if the
artist had no racist intent.
There was no confusion
about the intent here.
Emails sent out by the
mayor of Las Alamedas,
California,
talking about, you know,
now that Obama's elected,
we're going to have a
watermelon patch on the
White House front lawn.
What does this
image accomplish,
aside from the mayor
apologizing and stepping
down?
You know, is it satire?
Sure, it's satire, but is it
also a Rorschach test of how
you have someone
like, looking like,
Barack Obama taking office,
and people don't know what
to make of it,
don't know what to do?
Now we talked
about in this course,
at the very
beginning, racial symbolism,
you know, the money we
carry in our pocket.
You know, and again,
it's not showing up well,
but, you know, John C.
Calhoun in the corner there.
Let's not believe that
this is past history.
Let us recognize the
Republican Women's Group in
I--Inland, California sent
this out in the newsletter,
of Obama bucks.
He's got a
watermelon, the Kool-Aid,
a bunch of ribs and KFC.
This is our current
state of affairs.
Race is used in, in
the American landscape,
in our "post-racial" age, to
get us through circumstances
that we don't want to
call them as being say
class-driven, or
driven by gender anxiety,
or driven by
political anxiety.
Oh, it's all going to
be coded in racial ways.
But because, you know, we
don't want to be seen as
racist, we can't
talk about it.
We can show it, but we
can't talk about it.
So I really
want to end then,
and just bear with
me a couple minutes,
we've gone through
this entire course
thinking--sharing a
history of social,
political, intellectual,
cultural history,
of the different ways
citizenship has been
wrestled over, the
way race has been used.
The TAs, I hope you will
actually join me in giving,
giving them a round of
applause for helping us
through this way and through
these incredibly interesting
and, and, and
vexed conversations.
Congratulations.
Thank you so
much for your help.
Now I always do something
a little bit unusual here.
Are--Freshmen, are
there freshmen here?
Raise your hands.
Stand up, please.
Yes, stand up.
Stand up for
goodness' sakes.
I'm out of time, I
don't--I've got to be quick
about this thing.
This is one of your last
classes of freshmen year,
and I hope that your
experience here has been
exciting and wonderful, and
I also hope that people will
join me in congratulating
you in navigating
which--what has been a
horrible year at Yale for
all these reasons we know.
And I hope that you will
leave this year armed to
become a better
citizen at Yale.
So
congratulations, freshmen.
Professor Jonathan
Holloway: Sit down now.
Seniors here?
Stand up.
I know, because I
walked over with Julia.
This is one of your
last classes at Yale.
You're going to get a lot of
people congratulating you.
I'm not
congratulating you at all.
A lot of people are going to
be telling you how great and
wonderful you are.
Oh, in the back, can you
step over one foot because
you're blocking the
camera right there.
There we go.
People are going to tell
you how wonderful you are,
and you are wonderful, but
the fact of the matter is,
you now have a
responsibility when you
leave here, I think.
You may disagree
with everything I said.
That is actually
quite fine with me,
but I hope that you
will engage what I said,
and what the TAs have
said, and what you said in
section, that you will
understand it's incumbent
upon you to make
this a better place,
to make it, in
Barack Obama's word,
a more perf--perfect union.
And you've been
armed with the history,
even if you
disagree with it,
a history that I hope will
make you think and challenge
others when they start
spouting off in the most
unpredictable, or
maybe predictable,
ways.
So I want to congratulate
you personally for being
here, sticking through
it, getting through Yale,
and I hope everyone else
will congratulate you as
well.
Congratulations.
Professor Jonathan
Holloway: Sophomore,
juniors, I ain't got
nothing for you guys.
[Students laugh] So I really
raise the closing question,
the question that animates
this lecture: how is race
used?
And I simply
want to ask you,
how will you use it?
Thank you very much.
Thank you.